in Zimbabwe criticism is no longer
tolerated opinion and activism are
banned if you want to meet critics of
the government well you have to travel
at night we'd arrange to meet a man
called Oh Burt Masaru ray on a desolate
stretch of road he helps to run a
Teachers Union mr. masaru rate
represents teachers in rural Zimbabwe
and he's been advocating for higher
salaries but that's a dangerous job in
this country and it's made him a target
[Applause]
hi oh but thank you for coming okay he
had a bad limp and a story about a
terrifying visit which followed his
request for an increase in pay at least
I saw eight people with gun tortoise
some with ak-47 guns so one person with
a pistol in the lake masters over their
faces these guys break into my house
there are as my wife a demanding to know
where was the attack took place two days
before we met him in the union rep it
was clearly traumatized and they took me
to some bush they stripped me naked
after stripping me naked
they were assaulting me all over my body
forcing me to roll all over the mat they
left me in the bush and naked did they
took my wallet they took everything that
was would be certain value or sticks
I won't listen to him I don't see him my
wife was devastated my family was
devastated my wife was supposed to write
an examination it's 8 a.m. so you
realize so this is for me but I didn't
being now but I think even mr. masaru
Rae received a terrible beating but he
doesn't regret his appeal teachers are
now paid the equivalent of one pound a
day the salary which can pay the bills
is salary which can pay for the
education of my kids and I was gonna pay
for the other care of my family that is
much too much to ask for human rights
lawyers told us over a thousand
activists and ordinary citizens have
been arrested in the past six months as
part of a government drive to quash
unrest the economy here is close to
collapse but government officials say
the lawyers are lying the civic leaders
society you should be faking abduction
you felt that you've been harassed he's
been tortured and you know that these
Europeans
it will point little money into account
in January Sky News was present when an
ordinary citizen was beaten by members
of the security forces the assault took
place in broad daylight on a residential
street in Harare the National Guard we
found the victim in rural Zimbabwe he
said he was targeted because the
soldiers thought he was a member of the
opposition party the MDC I told you my
shoe removal nononononono de zongo fanon
no we did my River I eat one they do no
213 in organic butter in the water vapor
now it kind of might secure indeed them
for which I am so J so it was holdout
was initially the police force denied it
claiming our pictures were taken in 2016
but they've changed their minds
informing us that two officers have now
been suspended still our interviewee is
skeptical in solution from annuity can I
don't worry about the agenda 2016 obongo
song ji-sun log and I made this awkward
the dream of a democratic Zimbabwe is in
tatters
just ask five community workers who were
jailed for trying to overthrow the state
we watched as they were released on bail
no one wants to greet or embrace the
activists outside the front gate of the
prison so I think they're gonna do it
somewhere else
they were locked up for three weeks on
their return from a civil rights
conference overseas and the group seemed
relieved we are innocent citizens in in
is supposed to be free Zimbabwe entry
you just get arrested before
participating in eviction that's
ridiculous employment the desert a taste
of freedom on a dirt track near chicka
Ruby jail but these advocates and
activists know it could be brief John
sparks Sky News in Zimbabwe